其他人：我啊来吧
Others: Alright, let's go.
其他人：妈的你都不知道还有多少个快递
Others: Damn, you have no idea how many packages are left.
Tasha: 你自己来看嘛
Tasha: Come see for yourself.
Tasha: 你来看来看来看
Tasha: Come on, come see.
Tasha: 谢哥谢哥
Tasha: Thanks, bro. Thanks.
Shure: 我操
Shure: Damn.
Tasha: 挑一件走
Tasha: Pick one and go.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Tasha: 你未来的梦想啊
Tasha: Your future dream, huh?
Tasha: 这不是啊
Tasha: That's not it.
Tasha: 哪有这么多
Tasha: There's not that much.
Tasha: 这一一长串啊
Tasha: This is a long list.
其他人：你是我姐
Others: You're my sister.
其他人：你知道那100左右一个花了多少钱
Others: Do you know how much those 100 or so each cost?
其他人：什么东西啊
Others: What is that?
其他人：如何使用
Others: How do you use it?
其他人：今天的活动赋予他家庭
其他人：需要帮忙吗
Others: Do you need help?
Lucia: 呃应该快了
Lucia: Uh, it should be done soon.
其他人：好好好
Others: Okay, okay.
Lucia: 理论上说
Lucia: Theoretically speaking.
Lucia: 他应该比现在完成度还要高一点
Lucia: It should be more complete than it is now.
Lucia: 但好像时间来不及了
Lucia: But it seems like there's not enough time.
其他人：这已经很漂亮了
Others: This is already beautiful.
Lucia: 我就只能简单的粘一下了
Lucia: I can only stick it simply.
Lucia: 唉头疼
Lucia: Ugh, headache.
Lucia: 看好这个的话
Lucia: If you look at this.
Shure: 这个颜色真好
Shure: This color is really nice.
Shure: 这颜色不
Shure: This color...
Lucia: 嗯这是怎么回事啊
Lucia: Hmm, what's going on here?
Lucia: 这个还嘚瑟
Lucia: This one is showing off.
Lucia: 哦没有没有
Lucia: Oh no, no.
Lucia: 它不是所有的鱼都要粘在这上面
Lucia: Not all the fish need to be stuck here.
Lucia: 就是它只是一个随机的效果
Lucia: It's just a random effect.
Lucia: 就这个这个
Lucia: Just this one, this one.
Violet: 错落有致才好看
Lucia: 对对对这个
Lucia: Yes, yes, this one.
Lucia: 我看本来是想让这个鱼头朝下的
Lucia: I originally wanted the fish head to face down.
Lucia: 怎么现在感觉好像
Lucia: Why does it feel like...
Lucia: 因为它这个有一个bug
Lucia: Because there's a bug.
Lucia: 就是这个鱼很轻
Lucia: This fish is very light.
Lucia: 所以就是如果说直接粘的话
Lucia: So if you stick it directly.
Lucia: 它可能会卡不住
Lucia: It might not hold.
Shure: 哈哈哈太牛逼了
Shure: Haha, that's awesome.
Lucia: 这样试试看
Lucia: Let's try it this way.
Lucia: 感到头秃
Lucia: 对如果把它随便布置在哪里也可以
Lucia: Yeah, if you place it randomly anywhere, it's fine too.
Lucia: 好热
Lucia: So hot.
其他人：啊是吗
Others: Oh, really?
Lucia: 开始疯狂赶DDL了
Lucia: Starting to rush the deadline like crazy.
Lucia: 哈哈哈好尴尬
Lucia: Hahaha, this is so awkward.
Lucia: 大写加粗
Lucia: Bold and capitalized.
Lucia: 对就如果不把他卡住
Lucia: Yeah, if you don't hold it in place,
Lucia: 他就会往一个方向倒
Lucia: it'll just fall in one direction.
Lucia: 因为本来应该用一个麻绳来挂这个鱼
Lucia: Because we were supposed to use a hemp rope to hang this fish.
其他人：麻绳会有这水手的感觉
Others: Hemp rope would give it a sailor feel.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia: 但是现在这个珠串
Lucia: But now with this bead string,
Lucia: 他本身如果是鱼网鱼丝线的话
Lucia: if it were a fishing net or fishing line,
Lucia: 他就会只能这样卡一下
Lucia: it would just hold it in place like this.
Lucia: 让他不要往下掉
Lucia: To keep it from falling down.
Lucia: 然后中间再给他穿几个吧
Lucia: Then we could thread a few more in the middle.
Lucia: 总是在临时改变计划
Lucia: Always changing plans last minute.
其他人：已经挺好了
Others: It's already pretty good.
Lucia: 你好
Lucia: Hello.
Lucia: 中间好像再放一条就可以了看一下
Lucia: It seems like adding one more in the middle would be enough, let's see.
Lucia: 好像差不多
Lucia: Seems about right.
Lucia: 这
Lucia: This...
其他人：个是你买的还是你写的
Others: Did you buy this or write this?
Lucia: 这个是买的
Lucia: This was bought.
Lucia: 这个其实是雨轩买的
Lucia: Actually, Yu Xuan bought this.
Lucia: 但是我因为我没有买明信片然后对
Lucia: Because I didn't buy postcards, so yeah.
Lucia: 所以我就
Lucia: So I just...
Lucia: 使用了宇轩的资源
Lucia: used Yu Xuan's resources.
Lucia: 先凑合一下吧
Lucia: Let's just make do for now.
Lucia: 好像还凑合
Lucia: Seems alright.
Lucia: 哈哈这边还有两个
Lucia: Haha, there are two more over here.
Lucia: 本来想
Lucia: Initially...
Lucia: 本来是想把他们做成一个门帘一样的
Lucia: Initially, I wanted to make them into a curtain-like thing.
Lucia: 挂在门口的
Lucia: To hang at the door.
Lucia: 但是因为这个鱼实在是有点轻
Lucia: But because this fish is really a bit too light.
Lucia: 啊所以就挂门帘的话不是很好挂
Lucia: Ah, so hanging it as a curtain isn't very practical.
Lucia: 嗯上面的那个地方
Lucia: Hmm, the top part there,
Lucia: 我看要不要再整理一下
Lucia: maybe I should tidy it up a bit.
Lucia: 整个
Lucia: The whole...
Lucia: 这个纱
Lucia: this tulle.
Lucia: 这纱好像也没有什么时间剪它了
Lucia: Seems like we don't have time to cut this tulle anymore.
Lucia: 这个就有点不整齐
Lucia: It's a bit untidy.
Lucia: 我犯强迫症了
Lucia: My OCD is acting up.
Lucia: 但是也没办法好像
Lucia: But there's nothing we can do about it, it seems.
Lucia: 理论上说应该把它放到这上面
Lucia: Theoretically, it should go right here.
其他人：哦
Others: Oh.
Lucia: 然后这个地方它就只会露出来
Lucia: Then this part will only be exposed.
Lucia: 折的这个地方就会就会整齐很多
Lucia: The folded part will be much neater.
其他人：对高
Others: Yeah, it's high.
Lucia: 对够不着
Lucia: Yeah, can't reach it.
Lucia: 哈哈我太矮了
Lucia: Haha, I'm too short.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 想想还有什么别的可以用的然后
Lucia: Let's think if there's anything else we can use.
Lucia: 总觉得这个鱼还还剩两条
Lucia: I always feel like there are two fish left.
Lucia: 把它放哪呢
Lucia: Where should we put them?
其他人：贴在这个窗户上呢
Others: How about sticking them on the window?
Lucia: 啊好像也可以先贴一下试试
Lucia: Ah, that might work, let's try it.
Lucia: 反正胶带比较多
Lucia: Anyway, we have plenty of tape.
Lucia: 这个东西买的最多了
Lucia: This is what we bought the most of.
其他人：贴在那个床头也可以
Others: You could stick them on the headboard too.
Lucia: 对试试
Lucia: Yeah, let's try it.
Lucia: 哎好看的
Lucia: Hey, it looks good.
Lucia: 就这样吧
Lucia: Let's leave it like this.
Lucia: 到处都是鱼
Lucia: Fish everywhere.
其他人：这个小企鹅好可爱
Others: This little penguin is so cute.
Lucia: 啊对对小鸟
Lucia: Ah, yeah, little bird.
Lucia: 专门买了一个
Lucia: I specifically bought one.
Lucia: 实际上是喜欢这个鸟很久了
Lucia: Actually, I've liked this bird for a long time.
Lucia: 刚好它是蓝色的
Lucia: And it's blue.
Lucia: 我就决定趁机买来放在这里
Lucia: So I decided to take the chance and buy it to put here.
Lucia: 哈哈哈趁机买了这个
Lucia: Haha, I took the chance to buy this.
其他人：趁机买来
Others: Took the chance to buy it.
Lucia: 对这个灯它可以亮
Lucia: Yeah, this lamp can light up.
Lucia: 它要是有点蓝色就更好了
Lucia: It would be better if it had a bit of blue.
其他人：哦
Others: Oh.
Lucia: 嗯这怎么开的来着
Lucia: Hmm, how do you turn this on again?
其他人：哦
Others: Oh.
Lucia: 这样对
Lucia: Like this, right.
Lucia: 白天的话是不是让他更亮一些
Lucia: Should we make it brighter during the day?
Lucia: 这好像已经最亮了
Lucia: This seems to be the brightest.
其他人：鱼的话可以把它照在上
Others: You could shine the light on the fish.
Lucia: 哎对
Lucia: Yeah, right.
Lucia: 没有啊
Lucia: Nope.
Lucia: 啊对好像就是纪念碑谷的设计灵感
Lucia: Ah, yeah, it seems like the design inspiration came from Monument Valley.
Lucia: 我特别喜欢那个游戏
Lucia: I really like that game.
Lucia: 把这线藏起来这
Lucia: Let's hide this wire here.
Lucia: 个往这一点
Lucia: Move this a bit over here.
Lucia: 嗯看看怎么摆好看
Lucia: Hmm, let's see how to arrange it nicely.
Lucia: 这边线会露出来就这样
Lucia: This wire will show if we do it like this.
其他人：床头柜的这个布也很好看啊
Others: The fabric on the nightstand looks really nice too.
Lucia: 这对这个布也是这么买的
Lucia: Yes, I bought this fabric the same way.
其他人：好不错不错
Others: It's nice, really nice.
Lucia: 这个布其实是可心发现了
Lucia: Actually, it was Kexin who found this fabric.
Lucia: 然后他买了绿色的我买了蓝色的
Lucia: She bought the green one, and I got the blue one.
Lucia: 本来想买一个床罩
Lucia: I initially wanted to buy a bedspread.
Lucia: 把这个大大的面积白盖一下
Lucia: To cover this large white area.
Lucia: 但是找不到那种好看的
Lucia: But I couldn't find any pretty ones.
Lucia: 蓝色就很难找
Lucia: Blue is hard to find.
Lucia: 就碎花的那种很好找
Lucia: Floral ones are easy to find though.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 不会铺就凑合一下吧
Lucia: If I can't set it up nicely, I'll just make do with it.
Lucia: 不看最上面那一点还是很好看的
Lucia: If you don't look at the top, it still looks pretty good.
其他人：对
Others: Yeah.
Lucia: 我想想最上面能怎么怎么办呢
Lucia: Let me think about what to do with the top part.
Lucia: 上面那个扎的地方我实在是强迫症
Lucia: The part where it's tied up bothers my OCD.
Lucia: 要范
Lucia: Drives me nuts.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ugh.
其他人：用白色的纸贴一下盖一下
Others: Just cover it up with some white paper.
Lucia: 对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 嗯然我想想
Lucia: Hmm, let me think.
Lucia: 美团外卖
Lucia: Meituan delivery.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 找个高个的人帮我摘一下
Lucia: I'll find a tall person to help me take it down.
Lucia: 要不谁个子比较高
Lucia: Or who here is tall?
Lucia: 我去问问看
Lucia: I'll go ask around.
Lucia: 有没有哪位同学个子比较高
Lucia: Is there any student here who is tall?
Lucia: 来帮我粘一个东西
Lucia: To help me stick this thing up.
Lucia: 谢谢你高人
Lucia: Thank you, tall person.
Lucia: 谢谢你高人高
Lucia: Thank you, really tall person.
Lucia: 就是这个这个鱼
Lucia: It's this, this fish.
其他人：可以踩吗这个床
Others: Can we step on this bed?
Lucia: 呃踩吧踩吧没事哈哈
Lucia: Uh, step on it, it's fine, haha.
Lucia: 就这个鱼
Lucia: Just this fish.
Lucia: 你看他如果粘在这的话
Lucia: If you stick it here...
Lucia: 上面这就会漏出来
Lucia: It'll leak out from the top.
Lucia: 我想把他往就是粘到里面
Lucia: I want to stick it inside.
其他人：粘这吧
Others: Stick it here.
Lucia: 对就是上面一些
Lucia: Yeah, just some on top.
Lucia: 这样
Lucia: Like this.
Lucia: 就是能让他就是只有这个地方漏出来
Lucia: So only this part will leak out.
Lucia: 对往里粘
Lucia: Yes, stick it inside.
Lucia: 呃稍等我拿一下那个胶带在哪
Lucia: Uh, hold on, let me get the tape.
其他人：对胶带再长一点
Others: Yeah, make the tape longer.
Lucia: 对在这
Lucia: Yeah, it's here.
Lucia: 就把它对边能翻到里面去就更好一些
Lucia: Just fold it over to the inside, it'll be better.
Lucia: 啊sorry
Lucia: Ah, sorry.
其他人：哎你这个是胶带吗
Others: Hey, is this tape?
Lucia: 是美纹纸
Lucia: It's masking tape.
Lucia: 因为害怕就是给这个墙上留印子
Lucia: Because I'm afraid it'll leave marks on the wall.
Lucia: 就这个它撕下来不会有印
Lucia: This tape won't leave marks when removed.
其他人：先贴上
Others: Stick it on first.
其他人：这样
Others: Like this.
Lucia: 啊对
Lucia: Ah, yes.
Lucia: 就反正能尽量让他边不漏出来
Lucia: Just make sure the edge doesn't show.
Lucia: 就是就是
Lucia: Like, like...
Lucia: 让他视觉效果上只留这一部分就好
Lucia: Make sure visually only this part is visible.
Lucia: 哎呦sorry
Lucia: Oops, sorry.
其他人：感觉我怕它掉了
Others: I'm afraid it'll fall off.
Lucia: 我也有点怕你要不多多贴一点
Lucia: I'm a bit worried too, maybe add more tape.
其他人：因为这个这个纸我感觉不是很牢
Others: This tape doesn't seem very strong.
Lucia: 对是的这纸确实不是很牢
Lucia: Yeah, it's really not that strong.
Lucia: 因为
Lucia: Because...
Lucia: 它其实不是用来固定墙纸的那种纸
Lucia: It's not the kind of tape meant for securing wallpaper.
Lucia: 它是
Lucia: It's...
Lucia: 它是一个非常临时性的东西可以可以
Lucia: It's meant for temporary use, it can...
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Lucia: 哎呦然后这个能把他再往上一点
Lucia: Oops, can you move it up a bit more?
Lucia: 就塞进去
Lucia: Just tuck it in.
其他人：这样行吗
Others: Is this okay?
Lucia: 这样行对对对
Lucia: This is fine, yeah.
其他人：然后那你下边这个没关系
Others: Then it's okay if the bottom part isn't perfect.
Lucia: 没事
Lucia: It's fine.
Lucia: 下面这个一会还可以再调整一下
Lucia: We can adjust the bottom part later.
Lucia: 这个地方
Lucia: This part...
Lucia: 感觉放在这就可以了
Lucia: I think putting it here should be fine.
Lucia: 就可以了吧
Lucia: This should be okay, right?
Lucia: 先呃那个不用
Lucia: First, um, don't need that.
其他人：这样
Others: Like this.
Lucia: 那个专门放在中间就是
Lucia: That should go right in the middle.
Lucia: 哈哈那个专门中间让他耷拉下来的
Lucia: Haha, put that right in the middle so it hangs down.
其他人：然后这个就搁
Others: And then this just goes...
Lucia: 这对对这样在那里可以
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, like that over there.
Lucia: 就是有一个弧度的效果好嘞
Lucia: It gives a curved effect, great.
其他人：那这个你先拿着
Others: You hold this first.
Lucia: 而且这个沙滩很光滑
Lucia: And this sand is really smooth.
Lucia: 然后就更容易掉了烦死了
Lucia: So it's even easier to drop things, it's so annoying.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia: 就尽量能把它那个边都谢谢
Lucia: Try to get all the edges, thanks.
Lucia: 翻到里面去
Lucia: Tucked in.
Lucia: 哎呦不好意思把它粘住了
Lucia: Oops, sorry, it's stuck.
Lucia: sorry哎呦sorry
Lucia: Sorry, oops, sorry.
其他人：这样
Others: Like this.
Lucia: 啊对对然后
Lucia: Ah, yeah, yeah, and then...
Lucia: 那边也是
Lucia: That side too.
其他人：这感觉可以不用贴了其实
Others: I don't think you need to stick this actually.
其他人：这样
Others: Like this.
Lucia: 这个能把它我看一下笔画一下
Lucia: Can you hold it? I'll mark it.
Lucia: 啊啊啊我太矮了sorry嗯这个
Lucia: Ah, ah, ah, I'm too short, sorry. Um, this...
其他人：哦也可以
Others: Oh, that works too.
Lucia: 或许这样一下可以吗啊
Lucia: Maybe like this? Ah.
其他人：就贴这个吧
Others: Just stick this one.
Lucia: 谢谢对这个撕下来吧
Lucia: Thanks, yeah, tear this one off.
Lucia: 就往里一点然后哇对对对
Lucia: Move it in a bit, wow, yeah, yeah.
其他人：这样
Others: Like this.
其他人：行吗
Others: Is that okay?
Lucia: 看一下啊
Lucia: Let's see.
Lucia: 稍微整理一下给他
其他人：可以可以你这屋装饰的很好
Others: Looks good, you decorated this room really well.
Lucia: 啊好谢谢谢谢
Lucia: Ah, thanks, thanks.
Lucia: 感谢夸奖
Lucia: Appreciate the compliment.
Lucia: 干DDL我都疯了
Lucia: Working on this deadline is driving me crazy.
Lucia: 感觉还行
Lucia: It looks okay.
Lucia: 这个鱼
Lucia: This fish...
Lucia: 为什么多了一条鱼出来
Lucia: Why is there an extra fish here?
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Lucia: 嗯靠
Lucia: Hmm, damn
Lucia: 这个为什么成了管风琴效果
Lucia: Why does this sound like an organ now?
其他人：等一下我给你调回去
Others: Wait a minute, I'll fix it for you.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
其他人：调成钢琴
Lucia: 哦还能在那个APP上操作
Lucia: Oh, you can operate it on the app.
Lucia: 哦不是APP
Lucia: Oh, not the app.
Lucia: 电脑上
Lucia: On the computer.
Lucia: 好厉害
Lucia: That's amazing.
其他人：等下斯坦威
Others: Wait for the Steinway.
Lucia: 忘了，靠
Lucia: 哎啊
Lucia: Oh no.
Lucia: 好的好的哎
Lucia: Okay, okay, yeah.
Lucia: 那我上楼拿一下眼镜啊
Lucia: I'll go upstairs and get my glasses.
Lucia: 不是拿一下那个手机
Lucia: No, I mean my phone.
其他人：没关系你可以下去吃点好的
Others: It's okay, you can go downstairs and eat something nice.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Okay.
Lucia: 等一下
Lucia: Wait a moment.
Lucia: 是不是那个VPN又掉了
Lucia: Did the VPN drop again?
Lucia: 呵呵唉
Lucia: Haha, sigh.
Lucia: 等等等等
Lucia: Wait, wait, wait.
Lucia: 他怎么自动变成Hong Kong了
Lucia: Why did it automatically switch to Hong Kong?
Lucia: 我靠新的破铃声
Lucia: Damn, a new annoying ringtone.
Lucia: 好热
Lucia: So hot.
Lucia: 哈哈感觉自己一直在上窜下跳
Lucia: Haha, I feel like I'm always running up and down.